[Musique]
nous sommes le 15 mai bienvenue pour
cette édition du 7 8 les invités
aujourd'hui en plateau patrick 2 1 le
directeur du réseau entreprendre des
villes invitées pour évoquer la fête des
lauréats ce mercredi à versailles la
créateurs repreneurs seront à l'honneur
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
vitalité économique du département et
puis jean françois le saux professeur au
lycée descartes à montigny le bretonneux
elle nous donnera les détails sur le
lancement d'un ballon sonde avec ses
élèves un projet scientifique menée dans
le cadre notamment du club d'astronomie
l'établissement bienvenue à tous les
deux et bienvenue également à thomas
fasquelle élèves du lycées des cartes
qui participent à ce projet de ballons
sondes on va en reparler dans quelques
minutes tout d'abord il est question est
d'économies avec vous le responsable du
réseau entreprendre yvelines le 17 mai
vous allez donc organisé à versailles au
palais des congrès une grande soirée des
lauréats on va y venir dans un instant
mais peut-être déjà présenté un peu le
réseau entreprendre c'est un réseau
national à quel est son but la région
entreprendre c'est effectivement un
réseau national qui est une association
de chefs d'entreprise qui a pour
vocation d'aider d'accompagner les
créateurs de façon strictement bénévole
et sans prise de tête
ce qui veut dire que les membres de
l'association dans chaque département et
notamment dans les yvelines sont d une
part des patrons de pme d'autre part des
dirigeants de groupes plus importants
et troisièmement des professions
libérales pour 85% de nos membres en
activité et 15% sont retirés des
affaires faciles ont pris une rue près
de soissons récente soit parce qu'ils
ont vendu leur société ils ont plus de
disponibilité faut donc aider ses
employés ses employeurs à développer
leurs entreprises leurs activités dans
les yvelines spécifiquement quel
résultat vous avez obtenu alors dans les
yvelines on accompagne chaque année une
vingtaine d'entreprises ce qui est le
cas de la promotion 2016 qui sont soit
des créations soient des reprises
et la spécificité de réseau entreprendre
dans les yvelines comme ailleurs est
d'accompagner des créateurs qui rend un
projet prévoyant la création d'un
minimum de 5 à 10 emplois dans les deux
à trois ans quelle est la durée de vie
en général sur les autres promotions
vous avez pu accompagner ces entreprises
réactions sont pérennes aujourd'hui
alors on a c'est un des points de
satisfaction effectivement de notre
notre organisation
puisqu'on a un taux de pérennité à 3 ans
qui est 91 % des entreprises
accompagnées à 5 1 qui est de 85%
vous allez y et elle remettre en phase
une moyenne nationale de 50 à 60% vous
l'avais dit il ya deux axes dans la
reprise d'entreprises et la création
d'entreprise
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui marche le
mieux est ce qu il ya beaucoup d
entrepreneurs qui se lancent avec des
nouvelles idées de nouvelles entreprises
ou est ce qu'on préfère aussi s'assurer
aussi d'une entreprise déjà existante
pour ensuite la re développer les
reprises représente à peu près 20% des
projets qui ont accompagné ce qui veut
dire que 80 % sont des dix créations
le profil des créateurs j'allais dire on
a 3 3 grandes catégories d'une part le
profil classique du créateur entre 30 et
45 ans qui a une première expérience un
peu de réseau un peu d'argent et qui
décide de lancer son activité mais elle
a aujourd'hui près de 40 % de nos
porteurs de projets sont des jeunes
créateurs qui sont soit encore étudiants
soit qui viennent sortir d'études
d'ingénieur ou de d'école de commerce et
qui décident de créer leur entreprise
tout de suite à la sortie c'est à dire
qu'on se lance très jeune c'était
peut-être pas le cas par le passé
aujourd'hui on se lance très jeune dans
des activités de création d'entreprise
absolument
ça veut dire que dans toutes les écoles
de commerce et toute l'école
d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui il ya une une
option entrepreneuriat qui est proposé
aux étudiants et on constate de très
beaux projets qui viennent de la part de
de la part de deux créateurs tout de
suite à la sortie voire même pendant
qu'ils sont encore étudiants pour
valoriser cette promotion assez
différentes promotions chaque année vous
organisez donc cette soirée à des
longueurs on va revoir des images
pendant qu'on
que nous parlons en plateau des années
précédentes la spécificité de la
promotion de cette année sur ces
lauréats 2016 alors comme comme
d'habitude on est présent dans tout le
département et dans tous les types
d'activités on peut et donc cette année
encore la fête des lauréats sera
organisée est organisée au sein du
palais des congrès de versailles avec un
parent qui est un parrain emblématique
cette année puisqu'il s'agit de daniel
herrero le fameux rugbyman est entré sur
le 15 mai voilà qui célèbre à cause de
son bandana rouge et de ses grands
cheveux blancs cheveux gris pardon mais
qui est également un intervenant à
sciences po à l'essec qui est l'auteur
d'un certain nombre de livres qui fait
du coaching en entreprise du conseil en
entreprise pour répondre à votre
question des spécificités ou peut citer
quelques deux ou trois exemples de deux
lauréats un petit peu atypique on a
d'abord là le bonheur de d'avoir parmi
nos lauréats la plus jeune entrepreneuse
de france philippines dolbeau qui a créé
sa structure à l'âge de 16 ans donc on
voit que on arrive à les créateurs
d'entreprise très très jeune arrive
voilà avec son projet new school qui est
promis à un grand avenir
parmi les choses un petit peu atypique
on peut citer le comptoir des pêcheurs
trottoirs les pêcheurs qui est le blabla
car de la pêche et qui se propose de de
réunir toute la communauté des pêcheurs
à la ligne aussi bien en mer quand nos
deux ou encore
on a deux jeunes de jeunes créateurs qui
se sortir de leur école de commerce un
propose un projet qui s'appelle la quête
qui permet de dire italy's et l'offrande
qui est fait à la messe du dimanche
il ya de mettre la main à la poche pour
sortir ces quelques pièces de monnaie et
bien les les paroissiens on pourra
sortir leur iphone et et faire don de
leurs offrandes de la quête à travers
l'art il ya quelques exemples et on aura
bien évidemment l'occasion de reparler
de ces différentes entreprises dans nos
différentes éditions du journal et nos
magazines sur notre antenne
juste un dernier mot si un jeune
entrepreneur décide de se lancer a
besoin d'un petit peu d'elle il peut se
tourner vers le réseau entreprendre
yvelines a bien sûr bien sûr les seuls
les seules conditions que que l'on
impose pour pour travailler sur un
projet la première chose c'est qu'ils
soient dans les yvelines bien sûr un
deuxième chose c'est que il dispose d'un
business plan établi qui prévoit 5 à 10
emplois minimum dans les deux à trois
ans ce qui veut dire que l'on à une
qualification à ce niveau là la
troisième chose c'est que le projet soit
pertinent que son financement soit
cohérent nous on va intervenir pour
aider vous déjà avoir travaillé sur son
projet avant de venir voir bien
évidemment tout faire adouber les allées
on parle pas d'une page blanche et vous
restez en plateau avec nous on les
éléments du business néanmoins on va
parler d'autres initiatives vous êtes
professeur je disais tout à l'heure au
lycée descartes à montigny en
physique-chimie et c'est l'un de vos
élèves en terminale scientifique qui
vous a accompagné par ce que vous aimez
mener des expériences en dehors des
salles de classe on va présenter les
choses comme ça on va voir d'ailleurs
quelques images qui ont été tournées par
thomas qui est ici en plateau vous avez
mis des ballons d'hélium dans des bus de
saint quentin en yvelines pour faire une
expérience cadre un peu atypique sa
chance de la salle de classe
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce jour là
vous voulez montrer que l'hélium et les
ballons d'hélium réagissent différemment
et donc essayer de comprendre
des choses qui sont parfois surprenants
du point de vue de l'expérience est en
fait l'on va voir que lorsqu'on accélère
alors qu'un ballon a tendance à reculer
et bien le ballon d'hélium lui s'avance
et donc on essayait de voir un petit peu
au travers de notre expérience de lancer
de ballon des choses un peu plus
qui ont trait à la physique et sortir du
ca drug du cadre de la salle de classe
ça permet de 2011 voilà je trouve que
c'est amusant c'est ludique c'est
intéressant puis c'est surtout très
concret parce que faire cette expérience
en salle de classe était vraiment pas
possible
j'aurais peut-être fait un bac
scientifique ce qui avait un professeur
comme vous dites ok littéraire sortir
des sacs de glace
c'est quelque chose que vous appréciez
j'imagine autres élèves de voix la
situation c'est très démonstratif c'est
vrai que en cours bas il nous faisait
montre des choses plus concrètes
puis là et que cette expérience c'est
vrai que ça nous fait découvrir ce qu'on
a fait en fin d'année c'est à dire
bientôt mais donc là c'est seb à lyon à
ces ballons à l'hélium là le prochain un
projet c'est un ballon toujours mais à
ballon-sonde alors ça va consister en
quoi donc en fait l'idée c'était de
faire quelque chose d'un petit peu
extraordinaire de 2 voilà de faire des
choses qui puisse vraiment passionné les
élèves et on va donc lancer adossé à la
fédération française de ballons
radioamateurs est adossé également radio
club de saint quentin en yvelines
on va lancer un ballon ce ballon il va
monter assez haut on l'espère il peut
monter à 20 25 30 voire un peu plus 33
km pour les records et une fois arrivé
là aux dons qu'ils gonflent
régulièrement du fait de la pression
qu'ils baissent il va exploser
il se retourne et donc il ya un petit
parachute il va tomber tout doucement on
va le suivre parce qu'il ya un petit gps
à l'intérieur on va le suivre donc ça
c'est travail des radios amateurs qui
vont nous aider
et donc on va le récupérer parfois 200
km de la région fin du site du lycée
descartes et donc on va les récupérer
trois heures après et donc on va essayer
de la doré d'obtenir également donc tout
ce qu'on avait dans notre nacelle dans
notre ballon donc c'est à dire la vidéo
parce que l'idée c'est vraiment de
pouvoir obtenir des images judo c'est le
cas de le dire
et puis également ses petits capteurs
que j'ai amené alors là c'est ce qu'on
est en train de tester donc ça c'est un
petit capteur de température une ctn là
c'est un autre modèle de capteurs de
température
et puis là c'est notre capteur d'ozone
donc on va essayer aussi avec des
capteurs rudimentaire parce que c'est
pas aussi élaboré que tout ce que
peuvent utiliser les professionnels de
vérifier que la couche d'ozone varie
lorsqu'on monte en altitude que la
pression va riches parmi les le capteur
de pression que la température varie
donc on va là on va essayer de faire
toute une série de mesures et ça suppose
bien sûr qu'on est étalonné calibré
vérifier tout ça avec l'aide du radio
club de saint quentin et avec des
ingénieurs à la retraite notamment et la
place des chalets dans tout ça comment
vous intervenez sur ce projet chaque
mercredi c'est après les cours on se
rejoint tous dans une salle est belle
par groupes d'élèves on travaille sur
chacun des projets dont kader est envoyé
sur toi ben moi je m'occupe de la vidéo
fiona il s'occupe du noeud de l'ozone
qui travaille sur la température puis
après on va tout mettre en commun on va
te mettre dans la nacelle et ça fera un
vrai projet de finale et ça permet quand
alors ça permet une cohésion un travail
en équipe ça permet de réviser des
notions peut être aussi pour le bac
bah le bac le km 0 c'est pas trop ça
mais ouais ça permet de voir un vrai
travail de groupe parce que bon on est
tous unis dans un seul et même projet çà
çà çà fin ça peut aider
et puis bah ouais c'est travailler
autour de projets comme ça ça peut
servir pour l'avenir
le décollage a pas encore eu lieu ça
sera quand alors le décollage il dépend
de plusieurs de plusieurs acteurs on va
dire donc la direction de l'aviation
civile qui doit nous donner son accord
parce qu'on peut pas lancer en région
parisienne un ballon comme ça dans les
airs qui fait quand même six mètres
cubes et donc du coup voilà il faut
qu'ils regardent un peu
les les dates qui puisse lui convenir on
a aussi surtout la météo
donc si la météo mauvaise évidemment de
balancer les ballons et donc pour
l'instant on avait dit que ça pourrait
se faire à partir du 17 mai et le 17 mai
sera pas possible donc deuxième date ce
sera mercredi suivant le 24 mai donc là
on espère que que voilà c'est sera
possible sinon on a encore tout le mois
de juin pour le lancer là on est sur un
profil d'élèves qui sont inscrits dans
une filière scientifique s qu'il ya
d'autres camarades d'autres élèves qui
s'y intéressent aussi qu'ils ne viennent
pas de cette terminale scientifique par
exemple je sais pas tous les profils
mais enfin il a majoritairement des
élèves de s
je sais pas si c'est parce qu'elle a
d'autres qui vient d'arriver aux élèves
de seconde et donc du coup ils sont en
section qui n'est pas encore déterminée
donc peut-être que après cette seconde
ils vont à s'orienter vers es vairelles
pourquoi pas après tout je pense que
l'idée c'est de faire partie d'une
équipe de de s'investir pendant un an
sur un projet mais après on peut très
bien ne pas avoir de d'appétence pour la
physique et pour la chimie mais pour
aimer une autre parti ou pour aimer tout
simplement rêver parce que je crois que
aussi c'est ça c'est fait rêver c'est ça
qui vous inscrivez bas puis c'est pas un
projet qu'on fera tous les ans donc ça
peut moi personnellement j'ai jamais
travaillé qu'autant de matériel donc ça
c'est moi j'aime bien et on viendra voir
la concrétisation lors du décollage de
ce ballon sonde dans les prochains jours
on l'espère merci à tous les deux merci
également d'être venu nous parler d'ici
là du réseau entreprendre en yvelines
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
aujourd'hui prochaine édition demain aux
horaires habituels et les replays bien
sûr sur notre application mobile et
notre site internet merci encore
[Musique]